so diaz i've never been more excited
my first time playing the jimmy jabs and
i'm destined to win look at my
competition
little miss haver brains the hay brains
and king brain made of
hay well you're forgetting about me i'm
also your competition yes but you don't
normally
care about games like these well i do
care about this game and you're gonna
lose because my brains aren't made of
hay
my brains are made of brains so
the perfect retort yes congratulations
on moving on to the second round
said i sarcastically oh you're still in
this i knew a uniformed officer
had been eliminated i just couldn't
remember which one okay we're both
graded insults let's move on
tell me why do you want to win this game
so badly honestly
i guess i still feel like my parents
don't accept my sexuality
and winning this will let me prove to
myself that as long as i feel good about
who i am
that's all that matters that's a load of
dung
you processed that parent stuff a year
ago you're right we're going to drag
brunch this sunday
no there's something private that is
fueling you
and when i find that private fuel i will
extract it to use as my private fuel in
my private fuel tank then
i will have a full tank of private fuel
and you will have an
empty tank of pride rosa so dance
i figured out why you want to win i
hacked your work calendar those
calendars are public everyone on the
system has access
i acted i'm a hacker anyhow you took a
vacation 14 days ago and yet you already
want another day off odd unless you
need it for a unique once-in-a-lifetime
occurrence
perhaps a proposal to your girlfriend
jocelyn
what you've been dating for a year you
met each other's parents and you just
got your nails done
to present her with a ring
jocelyn broke up with me what i want the
day off so i can sit alone listen to
death metal and get my head right
but what about my nail polish solve
getting my nails done made me feel
better for a second
ah this is a trick to throw me off i bet
things are better than ever
and you oh you really are crying
welcome to my most sadistic creation
the tangled nightmare of extension cords
that lives
in our supply closet your mission is to
untangle
your lamp's cord plug it in and then
pull yourself to it on your dolly and
turn it on oh nice hitchcock's coming
down from the speed
i have a chance freaks begin
is that grab the top one and you ain't
the bottom one oh my god that's what you
meant
although i'm open to whatever you want
to try here we go diaz i want to
apologize
i'm not talking to you oh oh
it worked the pegging worked what no
here we go
oh
gotcha you're never gonna catch me oh
yeah
yeah yes i did it and hitchhike's gonna
lose rosa and holtz are gonna beat him
rosa stop i give up i want you to know
i'm sorry for prying win this thing and
enjoy your day off
and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you and silently listen to death
metal
just know i'm always here
okay i'd like that
what no what are you freaks doing we're
leaving the competition
some things are more important than a
game no they're not
wait where are you going don't leave we
need you
why does the ceiling hate me
you like it not at all you can leave a
chance
you